Corrine Jean-Pierre accidentally posted
a tweet in the voice of Joe Biden we got
hairy legs green Jean Pierre the press
secretary tweeted out or someone tweeted
out from her account quote investing in
America means investing in all of
America when I ran for president I made
a promise that I would leave no part of
the country behind I don't think Karine
Jean-Pierre ran for president ever so
this means that from the White House
someone sent this from the wrong account
okay of course no one really thinks
Karen jump here is running her own
account no one thinks Joe Biden is
running his own account no one thinks
that Joe Biden knows what Twitter is the
reason this kind of a little Gaff
matters is it gives you another little
hint of why at least some people a
substantial number of people like Donald
Trump and why they even like his tweets
which are often extremely obnoxious and
sometimes kind of embarrassing they like
Trump and they like even the Trump
tweets because they know there's a real
person there